the following is a conversation with
jonathan height social psychologist at
nyu and critic of the negative effects
of social media on the human mind and
human civilization
he gives a respectful but hard hitting
response to my conversation with mark
zuckerberg and together him and i try to
figure out how we can do better
how we can lessen the amount of
depression and division in the world
he has brilliantly discussed these
topics in his writing including in his
book the coddling of the american mind
and in his recent long article in the
atlantic titled why the past 10 years of
american life have been uniquely stupid
when teddy roosevelt said in his famous
speech
that it is not the critical counts
he has not yet read the brilliant
writing of jonathan height i disagree
with john on some of the details of his
analysis and ideas but
both his criticism and our disagreement
is essential if we are to build better
and better technologies that connect us
social media has both the power to
destroy our society and to help it
flourish it's up to us to figure out how
we take the letter path
this is the lex friedman podcast to
support it please check out our sponsors
in the description and now to your
friends here's jonathan height
so you've been thinking about the human
mind for quite a long time
you wrote the happiness hypothesis the
righteous mind the coddling of the
american mind and today you're thinking
you're writing a lot about
social media and about democracy so
perhaps so if it's okay
let's go through the thread that
connects all of that work how do we get
from the very beginning to today with
the
the good the bad and the ugly of social
media
so i'm a social psychologist which means
i study
how we think
about other people and how people affect
our thinking
and in graduate school at the university
of pennsylvania i picked the topic of
moral psychology and i studied how
morality varied across countries i
studied in brazil and india
and in the 90s i began this was like i
got my phd in 1992
and in that decade was really when the
american culture war kind of really
began to blow up and i began to notice
that left and right in this country were
becoming like separate countries and you
could use the tools of cultural
psychology to study this
split this moral battle between left and
right
so i started doing that um and i began
growing alarmed in the in the early
2000s about how bad polarization was
getting and i began studying
um the causes of polarization you know
bringing moral psychology to bear on our
political problems
and i was originally going to write a
book to basically help the democrats
stop screwing up because i could see
that some of my my research showed
people on the right understand
people on the left they know what they
think you can't grow up in america
without knowing what progressives think
but here i grew up generally on the left
and i had no idea what conservatives
thought until i went and sought it out
and started reading conservative things
like national review
so originally i wanted to actually help
the democrats to understand moral
psychology so they could stop losing to
george w bush and i got a contract to
write the righteous mind and once i
started writing i committed to
understanding conservatives by reading
the best writings not the worst and i
discovered you know what you don't
understand anything until you look from
multiple perspectives and i discovered
there are a lot of great social science
ideas in the conservative intellectual
tradition
and so and i also began to see you know
what america's actually in real trouble
and this is like two thousand eight two
thousand like things are really we're
coming apart here so i began to really
focus my research on helping left and
right understand each other and helping
our democratic institutions to work
better okay so all this is before i had
any interest in social media you know i
was on twitter i guess like 2009 and you
know not much didn't think about it much
and then
so i'm going along as a social
psychologist studying this and then
everything seems to kind of blow up in
2014-2015 at universities
and that's when greg lucianov came to me
in may of 2014 and said john
weird stuff is happening students are
freaking out about a speaker coming to
campus that they don't have to go see
and they're saying it's dangerous it's
violence like what is going on and so
anyway greg's ideas about how we were
teaching students to think in distorted
ways that led us to write the coding the
american mind which wasn't primarily
about social media either it was about
you know this sort of a rise of of
depression anxiety
but after that things got so much worse
everywhere and that's when i began to
think like whoa something systemically
has changed something has changed about
the fabric of the social universe and so
ever since then i've been focused on
social media
so
we're going to try to sneak up to the
problems and the solutions at hand from
different directions
i have a lot of questions whether
it's fundamentally the nature of social
media that's the problem it's the
decisions of various human beings that
lead the social media companies that's
the problem is there still some
component that's highlighted in the
cuddling of the american mind that's the
individual psychology at play or the the
way parenting and education works
to make uh sort of emphasize
anti-fragility
of the human mind
uh as it interacts with the social media
platforms and the other humans through
the social so all that beautiful message
that should take us an hour or two to to
cover or maybe a couple of years yes but
so let's start if it's okay
uh you said you wanted to challenge some
of the things that mark zuckerberg has
said in a conversation with me uh what
are some of the ideas he expressed that
you disagree with okay there are two
major areas that i study uh one is what
is happening with teen mental health it
fell off a cliff in 2013 it was very
sudden um and then the other is what is
happening to our democratic and
epistemic institutions that means
knowledge generating like the
universities journalism
so so my main areas of research where
i'm collecting the empirical research
and trying to make sense of it is
what's happened to mental health and
what's the evidence that social media is
a contributor and then the other areas
what's happening to
democracies not just america and what's
the evidence that social media is a
contributor to the dysfunction so well
i'm sure we'll get to that because
that's what the atlantic article is
about but if we focus first on what's
happened to teen mental health
so before i read the quotes from mark i
i'd like to just give the overview um uh
and it is this
there's a lot of data tracking
adolescents
there's self-reports of how depressed
anxious lonely
there's data on hospital admissions for
self-harm there's data on suicide
and all of these things they bounce
around somewhat um but they're
relatively level in the early 2000s and
then all of a sudden around you know
around 2010 to 2013 depending on which
statistic you're looking at
all of a sudden they begin to shoot
upwards um more so for girls in some
cases but on the whole it's like up for
both sexes it's just that boys have
lower levels of anxiety and depression
so the curve is not quite as dramatic
but what we see is not small increase
it's not like oh 10 20
no the increases are between 50 and 150
um depending on which group you're
looking at um you know suicide for
pre-teen girls think thankfully it's not
very common um but it's two to three
times more common now or by 2015 it had
doubled between 2010 and 2015 it doubled
so something is going radically wrong in
the world of american preteens
and what we so as i've been studying it
i found first of all it's not just
america it's identical in canada and the
uk
um australia new zealand are very
similar they're just after a little
delay so whatever we're looking for here
but but yet it's not it's not as clear
uh in the germanic countries it's in
continental europe it's a little
different and we can get into that when
we talk about childhood
but
something's happening in many countries
um that and it started right around 2012
2013 it wasn't gradual um it hit girls
hardest and it hit pre-teen girls the
hardest so what could it be
nobody has come up with another
explanation
nobody it wasn't the financial crisis
that wouldn't have hit pre-teen girls
the hardest um there is no other
explanation the complexity here and the
data is of course as everyone knows
correlation doesn't prove causation the
fact that television viewing was going
up in the 50s and 60 in the 60s and 70s
doesn't mean that that was the cause of
the crime so what i've done
and this has worked with gene twenge uh
who wrote the book igen is um because i
was challenged you know when i when greg
and i put out the book the the coddling
of the american mind some researchers
challenged us and said oh you don't know
what you're talking about you know the
correlations between social media use
and and mental health they exist but
they're tiny it's it's you know like a
correlation coefficient of 0.03 or you
know a beta of 0.05 you know tiny little
things and one famous article said it's
no bigger than the correlation of mental
bad mental health and eating potatoes
which exists but it's like it's so tiny
it's zero essentially and that that
claim that social media is no more
harmful than eating potatoes or wearing
eye glasses it was a very catchy claim
and it's caught on and i keep hearing
that
um but let me unpack why that's not true
and then we'll get to what mark said
because what mark basically said here
actually i'll read it
by the way just to pause real quick uh
is
you you implied but just make it
explicit that the best explanation we
have now as you're proposing is that a
very particular aspect of social media
is there is a cause which is not just
social media but the the like button and
the retweet a certain mechanism of
virality that that was
invented or perhaps yeah some aspect of
social media is the cause good idea
let's be clear connecting people is good
i mean overall the more you connect
people the better giving people the
telephone was an amazing step forward
giving them free telephone you know free
long distance is even better videos i
mean so connecting people is good i'm
not a luddite um and social media at
least the idea of users posting things
like that happens on linkedin and it's
great it can serve all kinds of needs
what i'm talking about here is not the
internet it's not technology it's not
smartphones and it's not even all social
media
it's a particular business model in
which people are incentivized to create
content and that content is what brings
other people on and the people on there
are the product which is sold to
advertisers it's that particular
business model which facebook pioneered
which seems to be incredibly harmful for
teenagers especially for young girls 10
to 14 years old is where they're most
vulnerable
and it seems to be particularly harmful
for democratic institutions because it
leads to all kinds of anger conflict and
the destruction of any shared narrative
so that's what we're talking about we're
talking about facebook twitter i don't
have any data on tick tock i suspect
it's going to end up being having a lot
of really bad effects uh because the
teens are on it so much and to be really
clear since we're doing the nuance now
in this section lots of good stuff
happens you know a lot of there's a lot
of funny things on on twitter i use
twitter because it's an amazing way to
put out news to put out when i write
something you know you know you and i
you know use it to to promote things we
we learn things quickly um well this
could be now this is harder to
measure and we'll probably
i'll try to mention it because
so much of our conversation will be
about rigorous criticism i'll try to
sometimes mention
what are the possible positive effects
of social media in different ways so for
example in the way i've been using
twitter
not the promotion or any of that kind of
stuff it makes me
feel less lonely
to connect with people to make me smile
a little bit of humor here and there it
and that at scale is a very interesting
effect being connected across the globe
especially during times of covert and so
on it's very difficult to measure that
so we kind of have to consider that and
be honest
that there is a trade-off
uh we have to be honest about the
positive and the negative and sometimes
we're not sufficiently positive or in a
rigorous scientific way about the uh
we're not
rigorous in a scientific way about the
negative and that's what we're trying to
do
here
um and
so
that brings us to
the mark zuckerberg okay but wait let me
just pick up on the issue of trade-offs
because um
people might think like well like how
much of this do we need if we have too
much it's bad no that's a
one-dimensional
conceptualization this is a
multi-dimensional issue and a lot of
people seem to think like oh what we
have done without social media and
covered like we would have been sitting
there alone in our homes
yeah if all we had was uh you know
texting telephone zoom skype multiplayer
video games whatsapp um
all sorts of ways of communicating with
each other oh and there's blogs and the
rest of the internet yeah we would have
been fine did we really need the
hyper-viral platforms of facebook and
twitter now those did help certain
things get out faster and that did help
science twitter sometimes but it also
led to huge explosions of misinformation
and the polarization of our politics to
such an extent that a third of the
country you know didn't believe
what the medical establishment was
saying and we'll get into this the
medical establishment sometimes was
playing political games that made them
less credible yeah so on net it's not
clear to me if you've got the internet
smartphones blogs all of the you know
all of that stuff it's not clear to me
that adding in
this particular business model of
facebook twitter tick tock that that
that that really adds a lot more and one
interesting one we'll also talk about
is youtube i think it's easier to talk
about twitter and facebook
youtube is another complex piece that's
very hard to because youtube has many
things it's a content platform but also
has a recommendation system
that's
let's let's focus our discussion
on perhaps twitter and facebook but you
do in uh in this large document that
you're putting together uh on social
media uh called social media and
political dysfunction collaborative
review with the
chris bale that includes i believe
papers on youtube as well it does but
yeah again just to finish up with the
nuance yeah um uh youtube is really
complicated because i can't imagine life
without youtube it's incredibly useful
it does a lot of good things um it also
obviously helps to radicalize terrorist
groups and and murderers so um i you
know i think about youtube the way i
think about the internet in general and
i don't know enough to really comment on
youtube so i have been focused um and
it's also interesting
one thing we know is
teen social life change radically
between about 2010 and 2012. before 2010
they weren't mostly on every day because
they didn't have smartphones yet by 2012
to 14 that's the area in which they
almost all get smart phones and they
become daily users of the girl so the
girls go to instagram and tumblr they go
to the visual ones the boys go to
youtube and video games those don't seem
to be as harmful to mental health or
even harmful at all it's really um
tumblr instagram particularly that seem
to really have done in girls mental
health um so now
okay so let's look at the quote from
from mark zuckerberg
so uh at uh at 64 uh minutes and 31
seconds on the video i did i'm coded
this guy this is the this is excellent
this is the very helpful youtube
transcript youtube's an amazing program
um you ask him about francis haugen you
give him a chance to respond
uh and here's the key thing um
uh so he talks about what francis haugen
said he said no but that's
mischaracterized actually on most
measures the kids are doing better when
they're on instagram it's just on one
out of the 18.
and then he says
um i think an accurate characterization
would have been the kids using instagram
uh or not kids but teens is generally
positive for their mental health that's
his claim that youtube that uh instagram
is overall taken as a whole instagram is
positive for their mental health that's
what he says okay
now is it really is it really uh so
first just a simple okay now here what
i'd like to do is turn my attention to
another document that we'll make
available
so i was invited to give
testimony before a senate subcommittee
two weeks ago
where they were considering the platform
accountability act should we force the
platforms to actually tell us what our
kids are doing like we have no idea
other than self-report we have no idea
you know they're the only ones who know
like the kid does this and then over the
next hours the kids depressed are happy
we can't know that but but facebook
knows it um so should they be compelled
to uh to reveal the data we need that
so you raise just uh
uh to give people a little bit of
context in this document is brilliantly
structured
with questions studies that indicate
that the answer to a question is yes
indicate that the answer to question is
no and then mix results and questions
include things like does social media
make people more angry or effectively
polarized right
that's the one that we're going to get
to that's the one for democracy yes
that's democracy so i've got three
different google docs here because i
found this is an amazing way and thank
god for google docs it's an amazing way
to organize the research literature and
it's a collaborative review meaning that
so on this one gene twenge and i put up
the first draft and we say please you
know comment add studies tell us what we
missed and it evolves in real time in
any direction the yes or the oh yeah we
specifically encourage because i look my
the center of my research is that our
gut feelings drive our reasoning that's
that was my dissertation that was my
early research and so if gene twenge and
i are committed to but we're going to
obviously preferentially believe that
these platforms are bad for kids because
we said so in our books so we have
confirmation bias and i'm a devotee of
john stuart mill the only cure for
confirmation bias is other people who
have a different confirmation bias so
these documents evolve because critics
then say no you missed this or they say
you don't know what you're talking about
said great say so tell us um so i put
together this document and i'm gonna i'm
gonna put links to everything on my
website if users if you're sorry if
listeners viewers go to
jonathanheight.com
socialmedia it's a new page i just
created i'll put everything together in
one place there and we'll put those in
the show notes like links to this
document
and and other things like it though
that's right exactly right so yeah so
the thing i want to call attention now
is this document this document here with
the title teen mental health is
plummeting and social media is a major
contributing cause um so ben sasse and
chris coons are on the judiciary
committee they had a subcommittee
hearing on uh nate priscilli's bill uh
platform accountability transparency act
so they asked me to testify on what do
we know what's going on with teen mental
health and so what i did was i put
together everything i know with plenty
of graphs
to make these points that first what do
we know about the crisis well uh that
the crisis is specific to mood disorders
not everything else it's it's not just
self-report it's also behavioral data
because suicide and self-harm go
skyrocketing after 2010. um the
increases are very large and the crisis
is gendered
and it's hit many countries so i go
through the data on that so we have a
pretty clear characterization and
nobody's disputed me on this on this
part so can we just pause real quick
just so for people who are not aware so
self-report just how you kind of collect
data on this kind of thing sure you have
a
self-reported survey you ask people
uh how yeah how anxious are you these
days yeah how many hours a week do you
social media
that kind of stuff and then you do
it's maybe
you can collect large amounts of data
that way because you can ask a large
number of people that kind of question
and but then there's uh i forget the
term you use but more
uh so non-self-report data behavioral
data behavioral data that's right where
you actually have self-harm
and uh suicide numbers exactly so there
are a lot of graphs like this so this is
from the national survey on drug use and
health so the so the federal government
and also pew and gallup there are a lot
of organizations that have been
collecting survey data for decades so
this is a gold mine and what you see on
these graphs over and over again is
relatively straight lines up until
around 2010 or 2012. and on the x-axis
we have time years going from 2004 to
2020 on the y-axis is the percent of u.s
teens who had a major depression in the
last year that's right so when this data
started coming out around so gene
twang's book igen 2017 a lot of people
say oh she you know she doesn't know
what she's talking about this is just
self-report like gen z they're just
really comfortable talking about this
this is a good thing this isn't a real
epidemic and literally the day before my
book with greg was published the day
before there was a psychiatrist in new
york times who had an op-ed saying relax
cell phones smartphones are not ruining
your kid's brain and he said it's just
self-report it's just that they're
they're they're giving higher rates
there's more diagnosis but underlying
there's no change no because these gra
these it's theoretically possible but
all we have to do is look at the
hospitalization data for self-harm and
suicide and we see the exact same trends
we see also a very sudden big rise um
around between 2009 and 2012 you have an
elbow and then it goes up up up so that
is not self-report those are actual kids
admitted to hospitals for cutting
themselves
so we have a catastrophe and this was
all true before kovid covet made things
worse but we have to realize um you know
covet's going away kids are back in
school or back in school but we're not
going to go back to where we were
because this problem is not caused by
covid what is it caused by um well uh
just again to just go through the point
then i'll stop i i just feel like i'm i
just really don't want to get out the
data to show that market is wrong so
first point correlational studies
consistently show a link they almost all
do but it's not big
equivalent to a correlation coefficient
around point one typically um
that's the first point the second point
um is that um this the correlation is
actually much larger than for eating
potatoes so that famous line wasn't
about social media use that was about
digital media use that included watching
netflix doing homework on everything and
so what they did is they they looked at
all screen use and then they said this
is correlated with self-reports of
depression anxiety at like you know 0.03
it's tiny
and well but they said that clearly in
the paper but the media has reported as
social media
is 0.03 or tiny and that's just not true
what i found digging into it you don't
know this until you look at the there's
more than 100 studies in the google doc
once you dig in what you see is okay you
see a tiny correlation what happens if
we zoom in on just social media it
always gets bigger often a lot bigger
two or three times bigger
what happens if we zoom in on girls and
social media it always gets bigger often
a lot bigger and so
what i think we can conclude in fact
what one of the authors of the potato
studies herself concludes amy orban says
i think i have a quote from here she
reviewed a lot of studies and she
herself said that quote the associations
between social media use and well-being
therefore range from about r equals 0.15
to r equals 0.10 um
so that's the range we're talking about
and that's for boys and girls together
um and a lot of research including hers
and mine show that girls it's higher so
for girls we're talking about
correlations around point one five to
point two i believe gene twangy and i
found it's about point two or 0.22
now this might sound like an arcane
social science debate but people have to
understand public health correlations
are almost never above 0.2 so the
correlation of childhood exposure to
lead and adult iq very serious problem
that's 0.09 like the world's messy and
our measurements are messy and so if you
find a consistent correlation of 0.15
like you would never let your kid do
that thing that actually is dangerous
and it can explain when you multiply it
over
tens of millions of kids spending you
know years of their lives
you actually can explain the mental
health epidemic just from
social media use
well and then there's questions by the
way uh this is really good to learn
because i quit potatoes and it had no
[Laughter]
uh and it's a russian that was a big
sacrifice
um they're quite literal actually
because i'm mostly eating keto these
days but that's that's
that's funny that they're actually
literally called the potato studies okay
uh but
given this and there's a lot of
fascinating data here there's also a
discussion of how to how to fix it
what are the aspects
that if fixed would start to reverse
some of these trends
so if we just
linger on the sort of the mark
zuckerberg
statements
so first of all do you think
mark is aware of some of these
studies
so
if we if you put yourself in the shoes
of mark zuckerberg and the executives
that facebook and twitter
how can you try to understand the
studies like the google docs you put
together
to try to make decisions that fix things
is is is there a stable science now that
you can start to investigate and and
also maybe uh if you can comment
on the depth of data that's available
because ultimately
this is something you argue that the
data should be more transparent should
be provided but currently if it's not
all you have is maybe some leaks of
internal data
that's right and we could talk about the
potential you have to be very sort of
objective about the potential bias in
those kinds of leaks you want to
it would be nice to have a non-leak data
like
like yeah it'd be nice to be able to
actually have academic researchers able
to access in de-individuated
de-identified form um the actual data on
what kids are doing and how their mood
changes and and you know when people
commit suicide what was happening before
and it'd be great to know that we have
no idea
so what how do we begin
to fix social media would you say okay
so here's the most important thing to
understand
in the social sciences
you know we say is social media harmful
to kids that's a broad question you
can't answer that directly you have to
have much more specific questions you
have to operationalize it and have a
theory of how it's harming kids and so
almost all of the research is done on
what's called the dose response model
that is
everybody including the researchers are
thinking about this like let's they
treated this like sugar
you know because the data usually shows
a little bit of social media uses and
correlated with harm but a lot is so you
know think of it like sugar and if kids
have a lot of sugar then it's bad so how
much is okay
um but social media is not like sugar at
all it's not a dose response thing it's
a complete rewiring of childhood
so
we evolved as a species in which kids
play in mixed age groups they learn the
skills of adulthood they're always
playing and working and learning and
doing errands that's normal childhood
that's how you develop your brain that's
you become a mature adult until the
1990s in the 1990s we dropped all that
we said it's too dangerous if we let you
outside you'll be kidnapped so we
completely we began rewiring childhood
in the 90s before social media
and that's a big part of the story
i'm a big fan of leonardo skinnezy who
wrote the book free range kids if there
are any parents listening to this please
buy lenora's book free range kids and
then go to letgrow.org it's a nonprofit
that lenora and i started with peter
gray and
daniel shukman
to help change the laws and the norms
around letting kids out to play they
need free play so that's the the big
picture they need free play
and we started stopping that in the 90s
that we reduced it and then
gen z kids born in 1996 they're the
first people in history to get on social
media before puberty
millennials didn't get it until they
were in college but gen z they get it
because you can lie you just lie about
your age
they so they really begin to get on
around 2009-2010
and boom two years later they're
depressed it's not because they ate too
much sugar necessarily it's because
even normal social interactions that
kids had in the early 2000s largely well
they decline because now everything's
through the phone
and that's what i'm trying to get across
that it's not just a dose response thing
it's imagine
imagine one middle school where everyone
has an instagram account and it's
constant drama everyone's constantly
checking and posting and worrying and
imagine going through puberty that way
versus imagine there was a policy no
phones in school you have to check them
in a locker no one can have an instagram
account all the parents are on board
parents only let their kids have
instagram because the kid says everyone
else has it we're and that's we're stuck
in a social dilemma we're stuck in a
trap so
what's the solution keep kids off until
they're done with puberty there's a new
study actually by amy orban and andy
schabilski showing that the damage is
greatest
for girls between 11 and 13. so there is
no way to make it safe for pre-teens or
even 13 14 year olds we've gotta kids
should simply not be allowed on
these business models
where you're the product they should not
be allowed until you're 16. we need to
raise the agent and force it that's the
biggest thing so i think that's a really
powerful solution but
it's a
it makes me wonder if there's other
solutions
like controlling the virality of
bullying
so sort of if there's a way that's more
productive to childhood
to use social media so of course one
thing is putting your phone down but
first of all from the perspective of
social media companies i it might be
difficult to convince them to do so
uh
and also
for me as an adult who grew up without
social media
it's so
social media is a source of joy so i
wonder
if it's possible to design the
mechanisms
both the
challenge the ad driven model but
actually just technically the
recommender system
and how viral
how virality works on these platforms if
it's possible to design a platform that
leads to growth anti-fragility but does
not lead to depression
self-harm and suicide that like finding
that balance and making that is the
objective function not
not engagement yeah or
i don't think i don't think that can be
done for kids so i am very reluctant to
tell adults what to do i have a lot of
libertarian friends and i would lose
their friendship if i started saying oh
it's bad for adults and we should stop
adults from using it yeah but by the
same token i'm very reluctant to have
facebook and instagram tell my kids what
to do without me even knowing or without
me having any ability to control it
right as a parent it's very hard to stop
your kid i have stopped my kids from
getting on instagram um and that's
caused some difficulties but um but they
also have thanked me because they see
that it's stupid they see that what the
kids are really on it
what they post they see that the culture
of it is is stupid as they say so
um i don't think there's a way to make
it healthy for kids i think there's one
thing which is healthy for kids which is
free play we already robbed them of most
of it in the 90s
the more time they spend on their
devices the less they have free play
video games is a kind of play i'm not
saying that these things are all bad
but you know 12 hours of video game play
means you don't get any physical play
um so and ultimately physical play is
the way
uh to
to develop
physical to fragility and especially
social skills kids need huge amounts of
conflict with no adult to meet to
supervise or mediate and that's what we
robbed them of so anyway that we should
move on because i you know i get really
into the evidence here because i think
the story is actually quite clear now
there was a lot of ambiguity there are
conflicting studies but when you look at
it all together
the correlational studies are pretty
clear and the effect sizes are coming in
around 0.1 to 0.15 whether you call that
a correlation coefficient or a beta it's
all in the standardized beta it's all in
that sort of sort of range
there's also experimental evidence we
collect uh true experiments with random
assignment and they mostly show an
effect
and there's um eyewitness testimony
you know
with the kids themselves you talk to
girls and you pull them do you think
overall instagram is good for your
mental health or bad for you're not
going to find a group saying oh it's
wonderful oh yeah yeah mark you're right
it's mostly good no the girls themselves
say this is the major reason and i've
got studies in the google doc where
there's been surveys what do you think
is causing the is causing depression
anxiety and the number one thing they
say is social media so there's multiple
strands of evidence do you think the
recommendation is as a parent
that teens should not use instagram yes
twitter yes that's ultimately maybe in
the long term that there's no way
there's no way to make it safe there
it's unsafe at any speed look i mean it
might be very difficult to make it safe
and in the short term while we don't
know how to make it safe put down the
phone well now hold on a second
play with other kids via a platform like
roblox or multiplayer video games that's
great i have no beef with that
you focus on bullying before that's one
of five or seven different avenues of
harm the main one i think which does in
the girls
is not being bullied um it's living a
life where you're thinking all the time
about posting
because once a girl starts posting so
it's bad enough that they're scrolling
through and this is everyone comments on
this you're scrolling through and
everyone's life looks better than yours
because it's fake and all that you see
are the ones the algorithm picked that
were the night anyway so the scrolling i
think is bad for the girls but i'm
beginning to see i can't prove this but
i'm beginning to see from talking to
girls from seeing how it's used is once
you start posting
that takes over your mind and now you're
basically you're no longer present
because even if you're only spending
five or six hours a day on instagram
you're always thinking about it and when
you're in class you're thinking about
who how are people responding to the
post that i made between period you know
between classes um i mean i do it you
know i tried to stay off twitter for a
while but now i've got this big article
i'm i'm tweeting about it and i can't
help it like i check you know 20 times a
day i'll check like what are people
saying what are people saying this is
terrible and i'm a you know 58 year old
man imagine being a 12 year old girl
going through puberty you're
self-conscious about how you look and i
see some young women i see some
professional young women women in their
20s and 30s who are putting up sexy
photos of themselves like and this is so
sad so sad don't be doing this yeah see
i the the thing where i disagree a
little bit
is i agree with you in in the short term
but in the long term i feel it's the
responsibility of social media
not in some kind of ethical way not just
in an ethical way but it'll actually be
good for the product for the company
to maximize the long-term happiness and
well-being of the person
so not just engagement so consider but
the person is not the customer so the
thing is not to make them happy it's to
keep them on
that's the way it is currently right
that driven if we can get a business
model as you're saying i'd be all for it
and and i think that's the way to make
much more money so like a subscription
model where
the money comes from paying it's
it's not
that would work wouldn't it that would
help so subscription definitely would
help but i'm not sure it's so much i
mean a lot of people say it's about the
source of money but i just think it's
about the fundamental
mission of the product
if you want people to really love a
thing i think that thing
should uh
maximize your long-term well-being
in theory in morality land it should i
don't think it's just more than land i
think in business land too but that's
maybe a discussion for another day we're
we're studying the reality of the way
things currently are and they are as
they are as the studies are highlighting
so let us go then
in from the land of mental health for
young people
to the land of democracy by the way
in these big umbrella areas
is there a connection is there a
correlation between
the mental health of a human mind and
the division
of our political discipline oh yes oh
yes
so our brains are structured
to be
uh really good at approach and avoid so
we have circuits the front left circle
isn't over simplification but there's
some truth to it there's what's called
the behavioral activation system front
left cortex it's all about approach
opportunity you know
kid in a candy store and then the front
right cortex has circuits specialized
for withdrawal fear threat and of course
students you know i'm a college
professor and most of us think about our
college days like you know yeah we were
anxious at times but it was fun and it
was like i can take all these courses i
can do all these clubs all these people
now imagine if in 2013 all of a sudden
students are coming in with their front
right cortex hyper-activated
everything's a threat uh everything is
dangerous there's not enough to go
around
so
the front right cortex puts us into
what's called defend mode as opposed to
discover mode now let's move up to
adults imagine
a large diverse secular liberal
democracy in which people are most of
the time in discover mode
and you know we have a problem let's
think how to solve it and this is what
de tocqueville said about americans like
there's a problem we get together we
figure out how to solve it and he said
whereas in england and france people
would wait for the king to do it but
here like let you know the role person
do it that's the can do mindset that's
front left cortex discover mode
if you have a national shift of people
spending more time in defend mode now
you so everything that comes up whatever
anyone says you're not looking like oh
is there something good about you
thinking you know how is this dangerous
how is this a threat how is this
violence how can i attack this how can i
you know so so if you imagine you know
god up there with a little lever like
okay let's let's push everyone over into
you know more into discover mode and
it's like joy breaks out age of aquarius
all right let's shift them back into
let's put everyone in defend mode and i
can't think of a better way to put
people in defend mode than to have them
spend some time on
partisan or political twitter where it's
just a stream of horror stories
including videos about how horrible the
other side is and it's not just that
they're bad people it's that if they win
this election then we lose our country
or then it's catastrophe
so twitter and again we're not saying
all of twitter you know
most people aren't on twitter and people
that are mostly not talking about
politics but the ones that are on
talking about politics are flooding us
with stuff
all the journalists see it all the
major mainstream media is hugely
influenced by twitter
so if we put everyone if there's more
sort of anxiety sense of threat this
colors everything and then you're not
you know the great thing about about a
democracy and especially a you know or a
legislature that has some diversity in
it is that the art of politics is that
you can grow the pie and then divide it
you don't just fight zero sum you you
find ways that we can all get sixty
percent of what we want
uh and that that ends when everyone's
anxious and angry so
let's try to start to figure out who's
to blame here
is it the nature of social media is it
the decision
of of
the people at the heads of social media
companies that they're making in the
detailed engineering designs of the
algorithm
is it the users of social media that
drive narratives like you mentioned
journalists
that want to maximize drama in order to
uh
uh drive clicks to their off-site uh
articles
is it just human nature
that loves drama can't look away from an
accident when you're driving by it is
there is there something to be said
about the reason i ask these questions
is to see can we start to figure out
what the solution would be
uh for to to uh to alleviate to
de-escalate not yet not yet let's first
we have to understand
um you know as as we did on the teen
mental health thing okay now let's lay
out what is the problem what's messing
up our country and then we'll we can
talk about solutions so it's all the
things you said interacting in an
interesting way um so human nature is
tribal we evolve for intergroup conflict
um we love war um we we uh the first
time my buddies and i played paintball i
was 29 um and we were divided into teams
with strangers to shoot guns at each
other and kill each other and we all
afterwards it was like oh my god that
was incredible like it really felt like
we'd opened a room in our hearts that
had never been opened but as men you
know testosterone changes our brains and
our bodies and activates the war stuff
like we've got more stuff and that's why
boys like certain team sports it's play
war
so that's who we are
it doesn't mean we're always tribal it
doesn't mean we're always wanting to
fight we're also really good at making
peace and cooperation and finding deals
we're good at trade and exchange so you
know
you want your country to you want a
society that has room for conflict
ideally over sports like that's great
that's totally it's not just harmless
it's actually good
um but otherwise you want cooperation to
generally prevail in the society that's
how you create prosperity and peace
and if you're gonna have a diverse
democracy you really better focus on
cooperation not on tribalism and
division
uh and there's a wonderful book by yasha
monk called the great experiment that
talks about the difficulty of diversity
in democracy and and and what we need to
do to
get this right and to get the benefits
of diversity
so that's human nature
um now let's imagine that the
technological environment makes it
really easy for us to cooperate let's
give everyone telephones and the postal
service let's give them email like wow
you know we can do all these things
together with people far away it's
amazing
um now instead of that let's give them a
technology that encourages them to fight
so early facebook and twitter were
generally lovely places um you know
people old enough to remember like they
were fun there's a lot of humor um you
didn't feel like you're going to get
your head blown off no matter what you
said um
2007 2008 2009 it was still fun these
were nice places mostly and like almost
all the platforms started off as nice
places
um but and this is
the key thing in the in the article in
the atlantic article
on babel on after babel the atlantic
article by the way is why the past 10
years of american life have been
uniquely stupid
yeah my title in the magazine was after
babel uh adapting to a world we can no
longer share that's what i proposed but
they they a b tested what's the title it
gets the most clicks and it was why the
past 10 years have been using the bible
the tower of babel is is a um
is a driving metaphor in the piece so
what first of all what is it what's the
top of babel what's what's babel what
are we talking about okay so the tower
babel is a story in early in genesis
where the descendants of noah are
spreading out and repopulating the world
and they're on the plane of shinar and
they say let us build us a city with a
tower to make a name for ourselves lest
we be scattered again and so it's a very
short story there's not a lot in it but
it looks like they're saying you know we
don't want god to flood us again let's
build a city and a tower
and to reach the heavens and god is
offended by the hubris of these people
um acting again like gods um
and he says here's the key line he says
let us go down and confuse their
language so that they may not understand
one another
so in the story he doesn't literally
knock the tower over but you know many
of us have seen images or you know movie
drama dramatizations where a great wind
comes and the tower is knocked over and
the people are left wandering amid the
rubble unable to talk to each other
so i've been grappling i've been trying
to say what the hell happened to our
society
beginning in 2014 what the hell is
happening to universities and then it
spread out from universities it hit
journalism the arts and now it's all
over companies
um what the hell happened to us and it
wasn't until i reread the babel story a
couple of years ago that i thought whoa
this is it this is the metaphor because
you know i've been thinking about
tribalism and left right battles and war
and you know that's easy to think about
but babel isn't like you know and god
said let half of the people hate the
other half no it wasn't that it's god
said let us confuse their language that
they none of them can understand each
other ever again or at least for a while
um so it's a story about fragmentation
and that's what's unique about our time
so
so meta or facebook wrote a rebuttal um
to my article they disputed what i said
uh and one of their arguments was oh but
you know
polarization goes back way before social
media and you know and it was happening
in the 90s and they're right it does and
i should i did say that but i should
have said it more clearly with more
examples but here's the new thing
even though left and right we're
beginning to hate each other more
we weren't afraid of the person next to
us we weren't afraid of each other
cable tv
you know fox news whatever you want to
point to about increasing polarization
it didn't make me afraid of my students
and that was new in around 2014 2015. we
started hearing getting articles
you know i'm a liberal professor and my
liberal students frightened me it was in
vox in 2015. and that was after greg and
i had turned in the draft of our
of our first draft of our coddling
article
and surveys show over and over again
students are not as afraid of their
professors they're actually afraid of
other students
most students are lovely it's not like
the whole generation has lost their
minds what happens is a small number
a small number are adept at using social
media to destroy anyone that they think
they can get credit for destroying
and the bizarre thing is it's never it's
rarely about what ideas you express it's
usually about a word like he used this
word
um or this you know this was insensitive
or you know i can link this word to that
so it's it's a it's they don't really
engage with ideas and arguments it's a
real sort of gotcha um prosecutor i'm
sort of like oh you know it's like a
like a witch trial mindset um
so so the unique thing here is there's
something about social media in those
years
that a small number of people
can sort of be catalysts for this
division they can start the viral wave
that leads to a division that's
different than the other division we saw
before it's a little different than
viral wave once you get some people who
can who can use social media to
intimidate you get a you get a sudden
phase shift you get a big change in the
dynamics of groups and that's the heart
of the article this isn't just another
article about how social media is
polarizing us and destroying democracy
the heart of the article
is an analysis of what makes groups
smart and what makes them stupid
and so
because as we said earlier you know my
own research is on post-hoc reasoning
just postdoc justification
rationalization the only cure for that
is other people who don't share your
biases and so if you have an academic
debate as like the one i'm having with
you know with these other researchers
over social media you know i write
something they write something i have to
take account of their arguments and they
have to take account of mine
when the academic world works it's
because it puts us together in ways that
things cancel out that's what makes
universities smart what makes them
generators of knowledge
unless we stop dissent
what if we say
on these topics there can be no dissent
and if anyone says otherwise if any
academic comes up with research that
says otherwise we're going to destroy
them and if any academic even tweets a
study
contradicting what is the official word
we're going to destroy them and that was
the famous case of david shore
who in the days after george floyd was
killed and there were protests and the
question is are these protests going to
be productive or they're going to
backfire
now most of them were peaceful but some
were violent and he tweeted a study he
just simply tweeted a study
done by an action african-american i
think sociologist at princeton
omar wasau
and wasa's study showed that when you
look back at the 60s you see that where
there were violent protests it tended to
backfire peaceful protests tend to work
and so he simply tweeted that study
and there was a twitter mob after him
this was insensitive this was
anti-black it i think he was accused of
and he was fired within a day or two
so this is the kind of dynamic this is
not caused by cable tv this is not cause
this is something new okay
just on a small tangent there
uh in that situation because it happens
time and time again you highlight in
your current work but also in the
coddling of the american mind
is the blame on the mob the mechanisms
that enables the mob or the people that
do the firing the administration does
the firing yeah it's all of them well
can i
i sometimes feel
that we don't put enough blame on the
people that do the firing
which is that feels like
in the long arc of human history that is
the place for courage
and for ideals right that's where it
stops that's where the buck stops like
is so if there's going to be new
mechanisms for mobs and all that kind of
stuff there's going to be tribalism yeah
but at the end of the day that's what it
means to be a leader is to stop
stop the mob at the door but i'm a
social psychologist which means i look
at the social forces at work on people
and if and if you show me a situation in
which 95 of the people behave one way
and it's a way that we find surprising
and shameful
i'm not going to say wow 95 of the
people are shameful i'm going to say wow
what a powerful situation
we've got to change that situation so
that's what i think is happening here
because there are hardly any in the
first few years you know it begins
around 2018 2019 it really enters the
corporate world there are hardly any
leaders who stood up against it
but i've talked to a lot and it's it's
always the same thing
you have these you know you know people
in their usually their 50s or 60s
generally they're progressive or on the
left
they're accused of things by their young
employees they don't have the vocabulary
to stand up to it
and they give in very quickly and
because it happens over and over again
and there's only a few examples of
university presidents who said like no
we're not going to stop this talk just
because you're freaking out no you know
we're not going to fire this professor
because he wrote a paper that you that
you you don't like
there are so few examples
i have to include that the situational
forces are so strong now i think we are
seeing we are seeing
a reversal in the last few weeks or
months a clear sign of that is that the
new york times actually came out with an
editorial
from the editorial board saying that
free speech is important
now that's amazing that the times had
the guts to stand up for free speech
because
you know they're the the people well
what's been happening with the times is
that they've allowed twitter to become
the editorial board twitter as control
over the new york times and the new york
times literally will change papers i
have an essay in politico uh with with
nadine strauss and steve pinker and
pamela pereski on how um the new york
times
retracted and changed uh an editorial by
brett stevens and they did it in a
sneaky way and they lied about it and
they did this out of fear because he
mentioned iq he mentioned iq and jews
and then he went on to say
it probably isn't a genetic thing it's
probably culture but he mentioned it
and the new york times i mean they were
really cowardly now i think they from
what i hear they know that they were
cowardly they know that they should not
have fired james bennett they know that
they gave in to the mob and that's why
they're now poking their head up above
the parapet and they're saying oh we
think that free speech is important and
then of course they got their heads
blown off because you know twitter
reacted like how dare you say this are
you saying racist speech is okay but
they didn't back down they they didn't
retract it they didn't apologize for
defending free speech
so i think uh i think the times might be
coming back
can i ask your opinion on something here
what in terms of the times coming back
in terms of twitter being the editorial
board
for
the prestigious
journalistic organizations um what's the
importance of the role of mr elon musk
in this
so
um you know it's all fun and games but
here's a human who tweets about the
importance of freedom of speech and buys
twitter
what are your thoughts on on the
influence
the positive and the negative possible
consequences of this particular action
so you know if he is going to succeed in
if he's going to be one of the major
reasons why we decarbonize quickly and
why we get to mars then i'm willing to
cut him a lot of slack
so i have an overall positive view of
him now where i'm concerned and where
i'm critical
is
where in the middle of a raging culture
war and this culture war is making our
institutions stupid it's making them
fail um this culture i think could
destroy our country and by destroy i
mean we could descend into constant
constitutional crises a lot more
violence you know not that we're going
to disappear not that we're going to
kill each other but i think there will
be a lot more violence so
we're in the middle of this raging
culture war it's possibly turning to
violence
you need to
not add fuel to the fire and the fact
that he declared that he's going to be a
republican and the democrats are the bad
party
and you know as an individual citizen
he's entitled to his opinion of course
but as an influential citizen he should
at least be thoughtful
and
more importantly
companies need companies need and i
think would benefit
from a geneva convention for the culture
war in which
because they're all being they're all
being damaged by the culture we're
coming to the companies what we need to
get to i hope is a place where um
companies
do they have they have strong ethical
obligations about the effects that they
cause about how they treat their
employees about their supply chain they
have strong ethical obligations
but they should not be weighing in on
cultural issues well if i can read the
exact tweak because part of the tweet i
like
he said in the past i voted democrat
because they were mostly the kind the
kindness party
but they have become the party of
division and hate so i can no longer
support them and will vote republican
and then he finishes with now watch
their dirty tricks campaigning against
me unfold
okay uh what do you make of that like
what do you think he was thinking that
he came out so blatantly as a partisan
because he's probably communicating with
the board
with the people inside twitter and he's
clearly seeing the lien
and he's responding to that lien he's
he's also opening the door to the
to the
potential bringing back um
the former president
onto the platform and also bringing back
which he's probably looking at the
numbers of the people who are behind
truth social
saying that okay it seems that there's a
strong lien in twitter
uh in terms of
the left
um and in fact from what i see it seems
like
um
the current operation of twitter is
the the the
the extremes of the left get outraged by
something
and the extremes of the right point out
how the left is ridiculous like that
seems to be the mechanism
and and but and then it's it's uh
that's the source of the drama and then
the left gets very mad at the right that
points out the ridiculousness and
there's this vicious kind of psychology
that's the polarization cycle that's
what that's what we're in there's
something that happened here that's
there's a shift where there's a decline
i would say in both parties towards
being shitty
okay but look what everything with the
parties that's not the issue yeah the
issue is should the most important ceo
in america the ceo of some of our
biggest and most important companies so
yeah so let's imagine let's imagine five
years from now that two different worlds
in one world the
the ceo of every fortune 500 company has
said i'm a republican because i hate
those douchebags or i'm a democrat
because i hate those nazi racists that's
one world where everybody declares
everybody puts up a thing in their
window everybody is it's cultural
everywhere all the time 24 hours a day
you pick a doctor based on whether he's
red or blue everything is culture war
that's one possible future which we're
headed towards the other is we say you
know what political conflict should be
confined to political spaces there is a
room for protests but you don't go
protesting at people's private homes you
don't go threatening their children you
don't go doxing them we have to have
channels that are not culture war all
the time when you go shopping when you
go to a restaurant you shouldn't be
yelled and screamed at um when you buy a
product you should be able to buy
products from an excellent company you
shouldn't have to always think
what's the ceo what is it i mean what an
insane world but that's where we're
heading so
i think that elon did a really bad thing
in in in launching that tweet that was i
think really throwing fuel on a fire and
setting a norm in which businesses are
going to get even more politicized than
they are and you're saying specifically
the problem was that he picked the side
as the head of yes as the ceo as the
head of several major companies
you know of course we can find out what
his views are you know it's not like
it's just i mean actually with him it's
maybe hard to know but you know it's not
that a ceo can't
be a partisan or have views but to
publicly declare it in that way in such
a really insulting way
um this is throwing fuel on the fire and
it's setting a precedent that
corporations are major players in the
cultural world i'm trying to reverse
that we've got to pull back from that
let me play devil's advocate here so
because i've gotten a chance to interact
with quite a few ceos
um
there is also a value for authenticity
so i'm guessing this was written while
sitting on the toilet
and
i could see in a day from now
saying lol just kidding
there's a there's a humor there's a
lightness
there's a chaos element and that's chaos
is not
yeah that's not what we need right now
we don't need more well so yes there's a
balance here
the chaos isn't engineered chaos it's
really authentically who he is
and i would like to say that there's i
agree with that that's a trade-off
because
if you become a politician so there's a
trade-off between
in this case maybe authenticity and
civility
maybe like
being calculating
about the impact you have with your
words versus just being yourself and i'm
not sure
calculating is also a slippery slope
both are slippery slopes you have to be
careful so when we have conversations in
a vacuum and we just say like what
should a person do
those are very hard but our world is
actually structured into domains and
institutions
and if it's just like oh you know
talking here among our friends like we
should be authentic sure
but the ceo of a company has fiduciary
duties legal fiduciary duties to the
company he owes loyalty to the company
and if he is using the company
for his own
political gain or other purposes or
social standing that's a violation of
his fiduciary duty to the company
now there's debate among scholars
whether your fiduciary duties the
shareholders i i don't think it's the
shareholders i think many legal experts
say um it's the company is a legal
person you have duties to the company
employees owe a duty to the company
um so he's got those duties and i think
he you know you can say he's being
authentic but he's also violating those
duties
so that's it's those it's not
necessarily he's filing a law by doing
it but he
certainly is shredding any notion of
professional ethics around leadership of
a company in the modern age
i think you have to take it in the full
context because
you see that the
he's not being a political player he's
just saying quit being douchey suppose
the ceo of ford says you know what
um let's pick a group well i i shouldn't
do a racial group because that would be
different let's just say uh you know
what um left-handed people are
douchebags i hate them like why would
you say that like
left-handed people what you said now is
not not either
funny or like-hearted because i hate
them it wasn't funny i'm not picking you
i'm saying that statement words matter
there's a lightness to the statement in
the full context if you look at the at
the timeline of the man there's
ridiculous memes and there's non-stop
jokes that my big problem with the ceo
of ford is there's never any of that not
only is there any of that there's not a
celebration of the beauty of the
engineering of the different products
it's all political speak
channeled through multiple meetings of
pr there's a there's there's levels upon
levels upon levels where you think that
there it's it's really not authentic and
there
you're actually by being polite by being
civil you're actually playing politics
because all all of your
actual political decision making is done
in the back channels that's that's
obvious here here's a human being
being authentic and actually struggling
with some of the ideas and having fun
with it i i think this lightness
represents the kind of positivity that
we should be striving for it's f it's
funny to say that because you're looking
at these statements and they seem
negative but in the full context of
social media i don't know if they are so
but look at what you just said in the
full context you're taking his tweets in
context you know who doesn't do that
twitter like that's the twitter
everything is taken in the maximum
possible way there is no context oh yeah
so this is not like
you know yes i wish we did take people
in context i wish we lived in that world
but now that we have twitter and
facebook we don't live in that world
anymore so you're saying
it is a bit of a responsibility for
people with a large platform to consider
the fact that
there is the fundamental mechanism of
twitter where people don't give you the
benefit of the doubt well i don't want
to hang it on a large platform because
then that's what a lot of people say
like well you know she shouldn't say
that because she has a large platform
and she should say things that agree
with my politics i don't want to hang it
on large platform i want to hang it on
ceo of a company ceos of a company have
duties and responsibilities and and you
know scott gallery i think is very clear
about this you know he criticizes elon a
lot as being a really bad role model for
young men
young men need role models and he is a
very appealing attractive role model so
i agree with you but in terms of being a
role model i think uh okay they don't
want to put a responsibility on people
but yes he could be a much much better
role model there yeah i mean to insult
sitting centers by calling them old i
mean that's you know
yeah i won't do both sideism of like
well those senators can be [ __ ] too
yeah but yes that's fair enough respond
intelligently as i tweeted to
unintelligent treatment yes
yes um so the reason i like it he's now
a friend the reason i like elon is
because of the engineering because of
the work he does no i admire him
enormously for that but what i admire on
the twitter side is the authenticity
because i've been a little bit jaded and
worn out by people
who have
built up walls people in the position of
power the ceos and the politicians who
built up walls and you don't see the
real person that's one of the reasons i
love long-form podcasting is it
especially if you talk more than 10
minutes it's hard to have a wall up yeah
it all kind of crumbles away so i don't
know but yes yes you're right that that
that um
is a step backwards to say
at least to me the biggest problem is to
pick sides to say i'm not going to vote
this way or that way that's um
be that like leave that to the
politicians
um you have you have much
like the importance of social media is
far bigger
than um
the bickering the short-term big of any
one political party it's a platform
where we make progress where we
um
develop ideas through
sort of rigorous discourse all those
kinds of things so okay so here's an
idea about social media developed
through social media from elon which is
um
you know everyone freaks out because
they think either you know oh he's going
to do less content moderations the left
is freaking out because they want more
content moderation the right is
celebrating because they think the
people doing the content moderation are
on the left
but there was a there was a one i think
was a tweet um where he said like three
things he was going to do to make it
better and was i would defeat the bots
or something but he said
authenticate all humans yeah and this is
a hugely important statement
and it's pretty powerful that this guy
can put three words in a tweet and
actually i think this could change the
world even if the bid fails the fact
that elon said that that he thinks we
need to authenticate all humans is huge
because now
we're talking about solutions here
what can we do to make social media a
better place for democracy a place that
actually makes democracy better
as tristan harris has pointed out
social media and digital technology the
chinese are using it really skillfully
to make a better authoritarian nation
and by better i don't mean morally
better i mean like more stable
successful
whereas we're using it to make ourselves
weaker more fragmented and more insane
so we're on the way down
we're in big trouble
and um
all the argument is about content
moderation and what we learned from
francis haugen is that what five or ten
percent of what what she what they might
call hate speech gets caught one percent
of violence intimidation content
moderation even if we do a lot more of
it isn't going to make a big difference
all the
all the powers in the dynamics changes
to the architecture and as i said in my
atlantic article uh what are the reforms
that would matter for social media and
the number one thing i said the number
one thing i believe is
um user authentication or user
verification and people freak out and
they say like you know oh but we need
anonymous like yeah fine you can be
anonymous but um what i think needs to
be done is anyone can open an account on
you know twitter facebook whatever as
long as you're over 16 and that's
another piece once you're 16 or 18 um
at a certain age you can be treated like
an adult you can open an account and you
can look you can read
and you can make up whatever fake name
you want
but if you want to post if you want the
viral amplification on a company that
has section 230 protection from lawsuits
which is a very special privilege i
understand the need for it but it's an
incredibly powerful privilege to protect
them from lawsuits
if you want to be able to post um on
platforms that as we'll get to in the
google doc there's a lot of evidence
that they are undermining and damaging
democracy
um then the company has this this
minimal minimal responsibility has to
meet
banks have know your customer laws you
can't just walk up to a bank with a bag
of money that you stole and say here
deposit this for me my name's john smith
you have to actually show who you are
and the bank isn't going to announce who
you are publicly but you have to if
they're going to do business with you
they need to know you're a real person
uh um not a criminal
and so there's a lot of schemes for how
to do this there's multiple levels
people don't seem to understand this
level zero of authentication is nothing
that's what we have now level one this
might be what elon meant authenticate
all humans meaning you have to at least
pass a capture or some test to show
you're not a bot there's no identity
there's nothing just
something that you know it's a constant
cat and mouse struggle between bots and
human you know so we try to just filter
out pure bonds
the next level up there are a variety of
schemes that allow you to authenticate
identity in ways that are not traceable
or kept so
some whether you show an id whether you
use biometric whether you have something
something on the blockchain that
establishes identity whether it's linked
to a phone whatever it is there are
multiple schemes now that companies have
figured out um for how to do this and so
if you did that then in order to get an
account where you have posting
privileges on facebook or twitter or
tick tock or whatever
you have to at least do that and if you
do that
you know um now
um now the other people are real humans
too
and suddenly our public square is a lot
nicer because you don't have bots
swarming around this would also cut down
on trolls you still have trolls who use
their real name but this would just make
it a little scarier for trolls um some
men turn into complete [ __ ] they can
be very polite in real life uh but some
men as soon as they have the anonymity
they start using racial slurs they're
they're horrible
one troll can ruin thousands of people's
day
you know i'm somebody who
believes in free speech
and so there's been a lot of discussions
about this and we'll
ask you some questions about this too
but
there's
the tension there is the power of a
troll to ruin the party yes that's right
so like this idea of free speech
boy
do you have to also consider
if you want to have a private party
and enjoy your time challenging
lots of disagreement
debate all that kind of stuff but fun no
like annoying person screaming
just not disagreeing but just like
spilling like the the drinks all over
the place
um yeah all that kind of stuff so um
see
you're saying it's a step in the right
direction
to at least verify the humanness
of
of a person while maintaining anonymity
but the
so that's one step but the further step
that's maybe
doesn't go all the way because you can
still figure out ways to create multiple
accounts and you can but it's a lot
harder so actually there's a lot of ways
to do this there's a lot of creativity
out there about solving this problem so
if you go to the social media and
political dysfunction google doc that i
created uh with chris bale and then you
go to
section 11 proposals for improving
social media
so we're collecting there now
some of the ideas for how to do user
authentication
and so one is world coin there's one
human-id.org
this is a new organization created by
an nyu stern student who just came into
my office last week uh working with some
other people
and what they do here is they have a
method of identity verification um that
is keyed to your phone so you do have to
have a phone number
um and of course you can
buy seven different phone numbers if you
want but it's going to be about 20 or 30
dollars a month so nobody's gonna buy a
thousand phones um so yeah you know you
can uh um you don't have just one unique
id but most people do and nobody has a
thousand so just there just things like
this that would make an enormous
difference so here's the way that i
think about it
imagine a public square in which the
incentives are to be an [ __ ] that the
more you kick people in the shins and
spit on them and throw things at them
the more people applaud you um okay so
that's the public square we have now not
for most people but as you said just you
know one troll can ruin it for everybody
if there's a thousand of us in the
public square and ten are incentivized
to you know kick us and throw [ __ ] at us
like it's no fun to be in that public
square so right now i think twitter in
particular is making our public square
much worse it's making our democracy
much weaker much more divided much it's
it's bringing us down
imagine if we change the incentives
imagine if the incentive was to be
constructive um and so this is an idea
that i've been kicking around i talked
about with reid hoffman last week and he
seemed to think it's a good idea
and it is
uh it would be very easy
to um rather than trying to focus on
posts what post is fake or whatever
focus on users what users are incredibly
aggressive and so people just use a lot
of obstetry and explanation exclamation
points
ai could easily code nastiness or just
aggression hostility
and imagine if every user is rated on a
one to five scale for that
and the default when you open an account
on twitter or facebook the default is
four
you will see everybody who's a four and
below
but you won't even see the people who
are fives and they don't get to see you
so they can say what they want free
speech we're not censoring them they can
say what they want um but if but now
there's actually an incentive to not be
an [ __ ] because the more of an
[ __ ] you are the more people block
you out
so imagine our country goes in two
directions in one things continue to
deteriorate and we have no way to have a
public square in which we could actually
talk about things and in the other we
actually try to disincentivize being an
[ __ ] and encourage being constructive
what do you think i i well this is
because i'm an ai person
and i've very much ever since i talked
to jack about the health of conversation
but look at a lot of the machine
learning models involved
and i believe that the nastiness
classification is a difficult problem
automatically i'm sure it is so i
personally believe
in
uh crowdsourced nastiness labeling but
in an objective way where it doesn't
become
viral mob cancellation type of dynamics
um but more sort of objectively is is
this a shitty almost out of context
with only local context
is this a shitty thing to say at this
moment because here's the thing no but
we don't care about individual posts no
no but it's all that matters is the
average the posts make the man they do
but but the point is as long as we're
talking about averages here if one
person has a misclassified post it
doesn't matter right
yeah yeah so but you need to classify
posts in order to build up the average
that's that's what i mean and so
i i really like that idea whatev the
high level idea of
incentivizing people
to be less shitty yeah because that's
what we have that incentive in real life
yeah that's right it's actually really
painful to be in a full-time [ __ ] i
think in physical
reality right and it's shut off it
should be it should be also a pain
to be an [ __ ] on on the internet and
there could be different mechanisms for
that i wish ai was there machine
learning models were there i did they
just aren't yet but how about how about
we have so one track is we have ai
machine learning models and they render
a verdict another class is crowdsourcing
you get correct and then and then
whenever the two disagree you have
you know staff at twitter or whatever
you know they look at it and they say
what's going on here and that way you
can refine both the ai and you can
refine whatever the algorithms are for
the crowd source and because of course
that can be gamed and people can only
hey let's all rate this guy as really
aggressive you know so so you wouldn't
want just to rely on one single track
but if you have two tracks i think you
could do it
what do you think about this word
misinformation that maybe connects to
our two discussions now so one is a
discussion of social media and uh
democracy
and then the other is the coddling of
the american mind i've seen the word
misinformation
misused or used as a bullying word like
racism and so on which are
important
concepts
to identify but they're nevertheless
instead overused yes um does that worry
you because that seems to be the
mechanism
from inside twitter from inside facebook
to label information you don't like
versus information that's
actually
fundamentally harmful to society yeah so
i think there is um there is a meaning
of disinformation that is very useful
and and helpful
um which is when you have a concerted
campaign by russian agents
to plant a story and spread it and
they've been doing that since the 50s or
40s even
that's what this podcast actually is but
it's a disinformation yeah you seem
really soviet to me buddy
um
it's subtle it's between the lines
okay i'm sorry but uh um so i think it
went to the extent that there are
campaigns uh by either foreign agents uh
or you know just by the republican or
democratic parties there have been
examples of that um
there are all kinds of concerted
campaigns
that are intending to uh to confuse or
spread lies uh this is the the soviet
the fire hose of falsehood tactic so
it's very useful for that all the
companies need to have pretty large
staffs i think to deal with that because
that will always be there and that um is
really bad for our country so rene
deresta um is is just brilliant on this
reading her work has really frightened
me and opened my eyes about how easy it
is to manipulate um to manipulate and
spread
misinformation and especially um
polarization the russians have been
trying for the since the 50s
they would come to america and they
would do hate crimes they would spray
you know swastikas and synagogues to
make you know in this very anti-black
slurs they try to make americans feel
that they're as divided as possible
most of the debate nowadays however is
not that it seems to be people are
talking about what the other side is
saying
so
um you know if you're on the right then
you're very conscious of the times when
well you know the left wouldn't let us
even say
could covet be from a lab like they
would like you literally would get shut
down for saying that and it turns out
well we don't know if it's true but
there's at least a real likelihood that
it isn't it certainly is something that
should have been talked about so i tend
to stay away from any such discussions
and the reason is twofold one is because
they're almost entirely partisan it
generally is each side thinks that what
the other side is saying is fate is is
his
misinformation or disinformation and
they can prove certain examples um so
we're not going to get anywhere on that
we certainly are never going to get 60
votes in the senate for anything
about that i don't think content
moderation is nearly as important as
people think it has to be done and it
can be improved
almost all the action is in the dynamics
the architecture the virality uh and
then the nature of who
who is on the platform you know
unverified people and how much
amplification they get that's what we
should be looking at rather than wasting
so much of our breath on whether we're
going to do a little more or little less
content moderation so the true harm to
society
on average and over the long term is in
the dynamics is it it's fundamentally in
the dynamics of social media not in the
subtle choices of content moderation aka
censorship exactly they've always been
conspiracy theories you know the turner
diaries is this book written in 1978 it
it introduced the the replacement theory
to a lot of people um timothy mcveigh
had it on him when he was captured in
1995 after the oklahoma city bombing
it's a kind of a bible of that that
fringe violent racist uh white
supremacist group
and that um so you know the the the
killer in buffalo was well acquainted
with these ideas they you know they've
been around but you know this guy's from
a small town i forget where he's from uh
you know but he was and he says in a
manifesto
he was entirely influenced by things he
found online he was not influenced by
anyone he met in person
ideas spread and communities can form
these like micro communities
can form with bizarre and twisted
beliefs
um and this is again back to the the
atlantic article i've got this amazing
quote from martin guri
let me just find it but he uh martin
guri he was a former cia analyst wrote
this brilliant book uh called the revolt
of the public or um
and he has this
um great quote he says he talks about
how
in the age of mass media we were all in
a sense looking at a mirror looking back
at us and it might have been a distorted
mirror but we had stories in common we
had facts in common um it was mass media
and he describes how the flood of
information with the internet uh is like
a tsunami washing over it has all kinds
of effects and he says
this isn't a comment in an interview in
vox he says
the digital revolution has shattered
that mirror and now the public inhabits
those broken pieces of glass so the
public isn't one thing it's highly
fragmented and it's basically mutually
hostile it's mostly people yelling each
other and living in bubbles of one sort
or another
and so you know we now see clearly
there's there this little bubble of of
just bizarre you know nastiness
in which you know the killer in christ
church and the killer in norway and now
in buffalo you know they're all put into
a community and posts flow up within
that community by a certain dynamic
so we can never stamp
those words or ideas out the question is
not
can we stop them from existing the
question is
what platforms what are the platforms by
which they spread all over the world and
into every little town so that the one
percent of whatever whatever percentage
of young men are vulnerable to this that
they they get exposed to it it's in the
dynamics in the architecture
it's a fascinating point to think about
because we often
debate and think about the
the content moderation the censorship
the ideas of free speech but you're
saying
yes that's important to talk about but
much more important is fixing the
dynamics that's right because everyone
thinks if there's regulation it means
censorship at least people on the right
think regulation equals censorship and
i'm trying to say no no that's only if
all we talk about is content moderation
well then yes that is the framework you
know how much or how little do we you
know but i don't want to talk about that
because all the action is in the
dynamics that's the point of my article
it's the architecture changed and our
social world went insane
so
can you try to steal man the other side
so
the people that might say that social
media is good for society overall
both in the dimension of mental health
as as mark said for teenagers teenage
girls
and for our democracy yes there's a lot
of negative things but that's
slices of data if you look at the whole
which is difficult to measure it's
actually good for society and it to the
degree that it's not good it's getting
better and better is it possible to
steal another point yeah
it's it's hard but i should be able to
do it um
i need to put my money where my mouth is
and that's a good question so on the
mental health front
um you know the argument is usually what
the the what they say is well you know
for communities that are cut off
especially lgbtq kids they can find each
other
so it's it's it it connects kids
especially kids who wouldn't find
connection otherwise
it
exposes you to a range of ideas and
content
and
it's fun
is there in the studies you looked at is
there inklings of
of data that's
maybe early data that shows that there
is positive effects in terms of
self-report data or
how would you measure behavioral
positive uh
it's difficult right so um
so if you look at how do you feel when
you're on the platform you get a mix of
positive and negative uh and people say
they feel supported and this is what
mark was referring to when he said you
know there was like 18 criteria and on
most it was positive and on some was
negative
so if you look at how do you feel while
you're using the platform a lot you know
look most kids enjoy it they're having
fun
but some kids are feeling inferior
cut off
bullied
so
if we're saying what's the average
experience on the platform that might
actually be positive if we just measure
the hedonics like how much fun versus
fear is there it could well be positive
but what i'm trying to okay so is that
enough steel manning can i use pretty
that's pretty good okay you held your
breath
but what i'm trying to point out is this
isn't a dose response sugar thing like
how do you feel while you're consuming
heroin like while i'm consuming heroin i
feel great
um but am i glad that heroin came into
my life am i glad that everyone in my
seventh grade class is on heroin like no
i'm not like i wish that people weren't
on heroin and they could play on the
playground but instead they're just you
know sitting on the bench shooting up
during recess so
when you look at it as an emergent
phenomenon that changed childhood now it
doesn't matter what are the feelings
while you're actually using it we need
to zoom out and say
how has this changed childhood can you
try to do the same for democracy yeah
um so we can go back to uh you know what
mark said in
2012 um when he was taking facebook
public
and you know this is the wake of the
arab spring i think people really have
to remember what an extraordinary year
2011 was it starts with the arab spring
um dictators are pulled down now people
say you know facebook took them down i
mean of course it was the citizens the
people themselves took down dictators
aided by
facebook and twitter and tell i don't
know if it was
or texting there were some other
platforms they used so
the argument that mark makes
in this letter to
potential shareholders investors
is you know we're at a turning point in
history
and um you know
social media is rewiring
we're giving people the tools to rewire
their institutions so this all sounds
great like this is the democratic dream
and what i write about in the essay is
the period of techno-democratic optimism
which began in the early 90s with the
fall of the of the iron curtain and the
soviet union and then the internet comes
in and you know people i mean people my
age remember how extraordinary it was
how much fun it was i mean the sense
that this was the dawning of a new age
and there was so much optimism and so
this optimism runs all the way from the
early 90s
all the way through 2011.
with the arab spring and of course that
year ends with occupy wall street and
there were also
big protest movements in israel and
spain and in a lot of areas martin guri
talks about this
so there certainly was a case to be made
that
facebook in particular but all these
platforms these were god's gift
democracy
what dictator could possibly keep out
the internet what dictator could stand
up to people connected on these digital
media platforms so that's the strong
case that this is gonna be good for
democracy
and then we can see what happened in the
years after now first of all um so in
uh in mark's response to you so here let
me read from what he said when you
interviewed him
he says
uh i think it's worth grounding this
conversation in the actual research that
has been done on this which by and large
finds that social media is not a large
driver of polarization he says that then
he says
most academic studies that i've seen
actually show that social media use is
correlated with lower polarization
that's the factual claim that he makes
which is not true
but he asserts that um study well
actually wait it's tricky because he
says the studies he has seen
so i can't so it might be that studies
he has seen say that but if you go to
the google doc with chris bale you see
there's seven different questions that
can be addressed and on one of them
which is
filter bubbles the evidence is very
mixed and you might be right that
facebook overall doesn't contribute to
filter bubbles but on the other six the
evidence is pretty strongly on the yes
side it is a cause he also draws a line
between the united states versus the
rest of the world right and there's one
thing true about that which is that
polarization has been rising much faster
in the us than in any other major
country so he's right about that so
we're talking about an article by uh
matt matthew against cow
uh and a few other researchers a very
important article we've got it in the in
the political dysfunction um database
and we should say that in this study
there's um like i started to say there's
a lot of fascinating questions that are
it's organized by whether studies
indicate yes or no question one is does
social media make people more angry or
effectively polarized
question two is does social media create
echo chamber these are fascinating
really important questions question
three is the social media amplified
posts that are more emotional
inflammatory or false question four is
the social media increase the
probability of violence question five is
the social media enable foreign
governments to increase political
dysfunction in the us and other
democracies question six the social
media decrease trust
seven is the social media strengthen
populist movements and then there's
other uh sections as you mentioned yeah
that's right but if you once you once
you operationalize it as seven different
questions um you know like so one is
about polarization and there are
measures of that the degree to which
people say they hate the other side and
so in this study by uh by boxell against
cow and shapiro 2021
um they looked at all the measures of
polarization they could find going back
to the 1970s for about 20 different
countries and they show plots you have
these nice plots with red lines showing
that in some countries it's going up
like the united states especially in
some countries it's going down and in
some countries it's pretty flat and so
mark says well you know if if
polarization's going up a lot in the us
but not in most other countries well
maybe facebook isn't responsible but so
much depends on how you operationalize
things are we interested in the straight
line regression line going back to the
70s
and if so well then he's right in what
he says
but that's not the argument the argument
isn't that
you know it's been rising or falling
since the 70s the argument is it's been
rising and falling since 2012
or so and for that now i just spoke with
i just i've been emailing with the
authors of the study and they say
there's not really enough data to do it
statistically reliably because there's
only a few observations after 2012. but
if you look at the graphs in their study
and they actually do provide as they
pointed out to me they do provide a
statistical test if you break the data
at the year 2000 so actually a
polarization is going up pretty widely
if you just look after 2000 which is
when the internet would be influential
and if you look just after 2012 you have
to just do it by eye but if you do it on
their graphs by eye you see that
actually a number of countries do see a
sudden sharp upturn not all not all by
any means but my point is mark asserts
he points to one study and he points
this over and over again i have had two
conversations with him he pointed this
study both times
he asserts that this study shows that
polarization is up some places down
other places there's no association
but actually
we have another section in the google
doc where we review all the data on the
decline of democracy and the high point
of democracy of course it was rising in
the 90s but if you look around the world
by some measures it begins to drop in
the late 2000s around 20 2007 2008 by
others it's in the early to mid uh 2010s
the point is there is a by many measures
there's a drop in the quality and the
number of democracies on this planet
that began in the 2010s and so um yes
mark can point to one study
but if you look in the google doc there
are a lot of other studies that point
the other way and especially about
whether things are getting more
polarized or less more polarized not in
all countries but in a lot so you've
provided
the problem
several proposals for solutions
do you think mark do you think
elon or whoever is at the head of
twitter
uh would be able to implement these
changes or does there need to be a
competitor social network system step up
if you were to predict the future uh now
this is you giving sort of financial
advice to me no no no
i
i can give you advice do the opposite of
whatever i've done okay excellent
but what do you think
uh when when we talk again in ten years
uh what do you think would be looking at
if it's a better world yeah so you have
to look at each the dynamics of each
change that needs to be made and you
have to look at it systemically and so
the biggest change for teen mental
health i think is to raise the age from
13 it was set to 13 in kappa in like
1997 or six or whatever that eight
whatever it was
it was set to 13 with no enforcement i
think it needs to go to 16 or 18 with
enforcement now there's no way that
facebook can say
um
actually so look at instagram the age is
13 but they don't enforce it
and and they're under pressure to not
enforce it because if they did enforce
it then all the kids would just go to
tick-tock which they're doing anyway but
if we go back a couple years when they
they were talking about rolling out
facebook for kids because they need to
get those kids they need to get kids
under 13. there's a business imperative
to hook them early and keep them
so i don't expect facebook to act on its
own accord and do the right thing
because
exactly when you have a social dilemma
you know like what economists call like
a prisoner's dilemma or a social dilemma
is you know generalized to multiple
people and when you have a social
dilemma
each player can't opt out because
they're going to lose you have to have
central regulation so i think we have to
raise the age um the uk parliament is
way ahead of us i think they're actually
functional the us congress is not
functional
so the parliament is implementing the
age-appropriate design code that may put
pressure on the platforms globally to
change certain so anyway my point is
we have to have regulation to force them
to be transparent and share what they're
doing there are some good bills out
there so i think that if the companies
and the and the users if we're all stuck
in a social dilemma um in which the
incentives to the
incentives against doing the right thing
are strong
we do need we do need regulation on
certain matters and again it's not about
content moderation who gets to say what
but it's things like the platform
accountability and transparency act uh
which is from senators coons portman and
klobuchar this would force the platforms
to just share information about what
they're doing like we can't even study
what's happening without the information
so that i think is just common sense um
senator michael bennett introduced the
uh the digital platforms commission act
of 2022
which would create a body tasked with
actually regulating and having oversight
right now the us government doesn't have
a body i mean the ftc can do certain
things we have things about antitrust
but we don't have a body that can
oversee or understand these things that
are transforming everything and possibly
severely damaging our political life
so i think there's a lot of oh and then
the the um
uh the state of california is actually
currently considering a version of the
uk's um the age-appropriate design code
which would force the companies to do
some simple things like not be sending
alerts and notifications to children at
10 or 11 o'clock at night just things
like that to make
make platforms just less damaging
so i think there's an essential role for
regulation and i think if the us
congress is too paralyzed by politics if
the uk and the eu and the state of
california and the state a few other
states if they enact legislation the
platforms don't want to have different
versions in different states or
countries so i think there actually is
some hope even if the us congress is
dysfunctional so there is because i've
been interacting with certain
regulations hitting
uh designed to hit amazon but it's
hitting youtube youtube folks have been
talking to me which is recommender
systems the algorithm has to be
has to be public i think
versus pro private which completely
breaks it's uh it's way too clumsy of
regulation that where the unintended
consequences break recommender systems
not for amazon but for other um for
other platforms that's just to say
that government can sometimes be clumsy
with the regulation he usually is and so
my preference is the threat of
regulation
uh in a friendly way encourages you
really should need it you really
shouldn't need it
my preference is great leaders lead the
way
in doing the right thing and i actually
honestly this to our earlier kind of
maybe my naive disagreement that i think
it's good business to do the right thing
in the in these spaces sometimes it is
sometimes it sometimes it loses you most
of your users well i think it's
important because i've been thinking a
lot about world war three recently yeah
and uh i it might be
silly to say but i think
social media has a role
in either creating world war iii or
avoiding world war three it seems like
so much of wars throughout history have
been
started through very fast escalation and
it feels like just looking at our recent
history social media is the mechanism
for escalation and so it's really
important to get this right not just for
the mental health of young people not
just for the polarization of bickering
over
over small scale political issues but
literally
um the survival of human civilization so
there's a lot at stake here
yeah i certainly agree with that i would
just say that i'm less concerned about
world war iii than i am about civil war
two i think that's a more likely
prospect yeah
yeah
yeah
can i ask for your why sage advice to
young people
so advice number one is put down the
phone
uh don't use instagram and and social
media but uh to young people in high
school in college
how to have a career or how to have a
life they can be proud of
yeah i'd be happy to because i i teach a
course at nyu um in the business school
uh called work wisdom and happiness and
the course is you know it's advice on
how to have a happy you know a
successful career
as a human being but the course has
evolved that it's now about three things
how to get stronger smarter and more
sociable
if you can do those three things then
you will be more successful at work and
in love and friendships and if you are
more successful in work love and
friendships then you will be happier you
will be as happy as you can be in fact
so the question is how do you become
smarter stronger and happier
um and the answer
to all three
is it's a number of things but it's you
have to see yourself as this like
complex adaptive system you've got this
complicated mind that needs a lot of
experience to wire itself up and the
most important part of that experience
is that you don't grow when you are with
your attachment figure you don't grow
when you're safe you have an attachment
figure to make you feel confident to go
out and explore the world in that world
you will face threats you will face fear
and sometimes you'll come running back
but you have to keep doing it because
over time you then develop the strength
to stay out there and to conquer it
that's normal human childhood that's
what we blocked in the 1990s in this
country so
young people have to get themselves the
childhood and this is all the way
through adolescence and young adulthood
they have to get themselves the
experience that older generations are
blocking them from out of fear and that
their phones are blocking them from out
of just you know hijacking almost all
the inputs into their life in almost all
the minutes of their day
so go out there put yourself out in
experiences you are anti-fragile and
you're not going to get strong unless
you actually have setbacks and
criticisms and and fights
so that's how you get stronger
and then there's an analogy in how you
get smarter which is you have to expose
yourself to other ideas to ideas that
people that criticize you
people that disagree with you
and this is why i co-founded heterodox
academy because we believe that that
faculty need to be in communities that
have political diversity and viewpoint
diversity but so do students
and it turns out students want this the
surveys show very clearly
gen z has not turned against
viewpoint diversity most of them want it
but they're just afraid of the small
number that will sort of shoot darts at
them if they you know if they say
something wrong so anyway the point is
um you're anti-fragile and so you have
to realize that to get stronger you have
to realize to get smarter and then the
key to becoming more sociable is very
simple it's just always looking it
through the other person's point of view
don't be so focused on what you want and
what you're afraid of
put yourself in the other person's shoes
what's interesting to them what do they
want
and if you develop the skill of looking
at it from their point of view you'll be
a better conversation partner you'll be
a better life partner
so there there's a lot that you can do i
mean i could say you know go read the
calling in american mind
i could say go read dale carnegie how to
win friends and influence people
but take charge of your life and your
development because if you don't do it
then
the the older older protective
generation
and your phone are going to take charge
of you
so on anti-fragility and coddling the
american mind if i may read just a few
lines from chief justice john roberts
which i find this is really beautiful
so it's not just about viewpoint
diversity but it's real struggle absurd
unfair struggle that seems to be
formative to the human mind he says from
time to time in the years to come i hope
you will be treated unfairly so that you
will come to know the value of justice i
hope that you will suffer betrayal
because that will teach you the
importance of loyalty sorry to say but i
hope you will be lonely from time time
so that you don't take friends for
granted i wish you bad luck again from
time to time so that you will be
conscious of the role of chance in life
and understand that your success is not
completely deserved and that the failure
of others is not completely deserved
either
and when you lose as you will from time
to time i hope every now and then your
opponent will gloat over your failure it
is a way for you to understand the
importance of sportsmanship
i hope you'll be ignored so you know the
importance of listening to others and i
hope you will have just enough pain to
learn compassion
whether i wish these things are not
they're going to happen
and whether you benefit from them or not
will depend upon your ability to see the
message in your misfortunes
he read that in a middle school
graduation yes for his sons his son's
middle school graduation
that's what i was trying to say only
that's much more beautiful yeah and uh i
think your work is really important and
it is beautiful and uh it's bold and
fearless and it's a huge honor to sit
with me i'm a big fan thank you for
spending your valuable time with me
today john thank you so much thanks so
much lex what a pleasure
thanks for listening to this
conversation with jonathan height to
support this podcast please check out
our sponsors in the description
and now let me leave you with some words
from carl jung
everything that irritates us about
others
can lead us to an understanding of
ourselves
thank you for listening and hope to see
you next time
you